sono qua i [ __ ]
sono qua daje cos'era da lontano e che
cazzo fai
ecco però si fa male si chiama le
bellissimo io non posso veramente
credere che io non sia stato neanche in
grado di montare una cazzo di webcam
[Musica]
siamo partiti da dio era gara siamo
partiti da dio pensate stessi sono io
sono io ciao
[Musica]
perché ora ragazzi siamo su playroom è
questo che dovevo farlo all'inizio porca
eva ma il cazzo si giochi farmi capire
piazza la playstation camera 50
centimetri da terra si sia già
controllato col pene non ti preoccupare
lo schermo deve apparire così riesce a
vedere la faccia il pavimento
ciao che cazzo vuoi di più
che devo fare vabbè aria prime le calze
che c'è tra fina il touchpad
o che cazzo
cos'è madonna che gol pazzini ma che
cazzo
as.tro si vabbè ascolta vabbè che son
magro ma sti cazzi vostri sensi
no no no non ti spaventa dovrai 9 la
grafica questo devo fare lo strisciare
robottini cos'è rilassati accompagnando
i tuoi piccoli amici in una passeggiata
sul tuo pavimento va bene ti stai
cagando nel joystiq ha già
ah sì qual è la mia se la sedia mia
quella lì ma perché a [ __ ] come come le
professioni si va ad esserlo su che
cazzo è un attimo mica come funziona se
perdi fermi da tenerci no no da tener 5
il 5 ago ioni io non ci ho bisogno dei
minion cattivissimo favi cioè questi è
stata famigli pupa della fama a stronzo
non ho capito terminati beh beh culo va
ma [ __ ] e faccio anche figo no
vabbè su dentro solo sta cosa vale tutto
il gioco malissimo poi torno indietro di
buttò fuori si monta ho capito non è
difficile hacker ma facebook away più
ballaben tecniche roma da bach in back
no che è successo tutto sparando dal mio
pene dei bambini a è così che nascono i
bambini e ragazzi è la cosa più
divertente che abbia mai fatto in tutta
la mia vita non so perché non ho
scoperto bene ragazzi siete dei dei
figli quale tendono a casoria tutti con
gli occhi e poi ragazzi sono proprio qua
dentro sé di vero va a caso va bene
senti 11 lo faccio uscire da ragazzino
se c'è qualcos'altro di roba strana tipo
gioca con adobe ha il robot ecologia è
chiamato bill bailey ha retto amico
metallico asobi per la stanza questa
attività ti permette di toccarlo
disegnano degli allora io non faccio
molesti e sugli asobi ricorda niente
pugni non ha più che altro non voglio
toccarlo che si eccita il suo trono a
sochi guarda che non tito pensare male
sembra che sto facendo cose bruttissime
prova bene a posto ciao sobri
passami dietro la riga molto viaggiato
la pensa così basta questa storia degli
scanner e che palle hai finito di fare
canzone è a fini corrientes so che devo
capire certi è casa mia se ti dico di
sederti senti ma no scusa facciamo che
non è successo niente superare una cosa
stai fermo sei fermo fermo non mi
guardare il pene stai terna non il mio
piede questo chiede ti piace all'appena
stai fermo fermo caso l'ho mancato
ok ma l'ho mancato ascolta 6 aspetta
aspetta aspetta ma dove cazzo vai calmo
caso calmo non lo fa calmo amico mio
posso rivelarsi una cosa questo sembra
proprio l'inizio di un porno ma il
problema non sono le tipe che non ti non
ti vogliono e che ebbe viveri e
l'atteggiamento che che c'hai che non ha
senso perché non puoi opportuna le
persone così c'è 1 st un cristiano sta
in casa sul divano cazzo pollice 6 libia
anche tu c'hai non se non hai le buone
maniere basile basi non guardarmi ma
basta basta a me dai la mia ma stringi
stringi la mano ma allora che ti danno
al nostro sia fatto senza però che si
chiama leporace
cos'è che ha cacciato
se papa no ma mi spiace non voler
ragazzi in giuro che non volevo poi che
cosa bella è la parte che tu stai
volando quindi fammi capire se questa
cazzo cos'è ma perché sembra che non si
stendono un super car mi ha cortesemente
avere ragazzi concluso che l'episodio è
stato alquanto strano perché c'è giocare
questi cosi è la cosa più strana al
mondo lo dico e non vedevo l'ora di
provarlo comunque veramente finito solo
che mi fate non so mi fanno un po senso
sinceramente però ragazzi è stato bello
finchè è durato levate kedar cazzo per
cortesia almeno per i ragazzi che un
crollo apple e adobe vogliono farmi
voglio soldi prima di concludere a
cioppi concludi tu per cortesia che non
c'è più voglia di pasta cosa grazie è
stato bello se sì sì no no tranquillo
dovrei chiudere episodio mi dai la mano
quindi ragazzi spero che video speriamo
io e lui torniamo entrambi che il video
vi sia piaciuto e niente ragazzo è bravo
bravo bravo ha fatto un passo avanti e
sono già progressi va bene a parte tutto
ragazzi spero che mi sia piaciuto cose
così vita è piaciuta al momento è un mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e con
i video trovate la descrizione no no
nella descrizione c'è un fatto così
perché va bene se sei così ti scrivo ci
vediamo un po subito di di bella ragazzi
sì più o meno quale colonie sono qua
daje
[Musica]
cos'era
da noi chi cazzo fai ecco però si pia
male si chiama le bellissime sud ischia
10 vita un po subito da ragazzi